Today I want to talk about water and the,
uh,
the law that surrounds drinking
water, uh, to talk about its quality.
Talk about, uh, what your
rights are to clean water, uh,
to also give you a sense of what
key threats are to drinking water.
Uh, what's your exposure might be, and a,
what we might do about it both
legally but also personally.
Uh, water is a critical component
of our environment in our bodies.
Your body is close to 70% water.
Uh,
you can go for several weeks, two
to three, on average without food.
You can only go for about
four minutes without air,
and you can go for maybe four or five
days without water before you die.
So water is absolutely critical.
And one of the key arguments I want
to make today is that it's a largely
neglected area of environmental law,
uh,
given the rapid increase
in our knowledge about, uh,
chemical threats to water quality and,
uh, where those threats come from.
So what are the major challenges in water
on a global scale? No, clearly one is,
is a waterborne diseases diarrheal
diseases are recognized to kill,
uh, between, uh, uh, four and
5 million people per year, uh,
in Africa, uh, oh aquifers,
they cross-property and jurisdictional
boundaries are a critical issue. Uh,
so many rivers form the boundary
between nations or between states.
Connecticut. Uh, the Connecticut River
is a very good example separating, uh,
uh, Vermont, uh, from New Hampshire
point source control versus a surface
runoff. Uh, we've had a long history,
uh,
in the last half of the 20th century of
trying to control a point sources or a
pipe releases to water supplies as opposed
to thinking about how chemicals may
accumulate on the surface, uh, and
then be washed into rivers, uh,
that are used for drinking water sources,
uh,
following serious rain events,
groundwater depletion. Uh,
the Oglala Aquifer in the southwestern
part of the United States and in,
in the western part of Texas, uh,
is being rapidly depleted, uh,
and it's contamination is well recognized.
Aquifers around the nation and most
industrialized countries, uh, are,
are now a more intensively tested
than they have been before.
And it's recognized that they contain
chemicals that never were anticipated to
persist or, or to migrate
private wells. Uh,
the safe drinking water act has been
established in the United States,
uh, to require testing and
control the chemical content, uh,
only in water systems that
supply more than 15 households,
15 or more households.
So if you grew up perhaps in a rural
part of the nation or you live outside of
new haven, uh, you may have your
own well, as I do, uh, so I have a,
I have a 600 foot deep. Well, and,
uh, when I purchased my house, I was,
I was quite happy with that prospect
thinking that a water on the surface who
would need to be filtered
down through the soil, uh,
before it got down into the well.
And it was quite striking. A,
I had quite a lesson from a, a well
driller. My well went dry one day.
I didn't know what happened.
Uh,
so I called the well driller and he
came out and it was pretty remarkable.
A lesson for me.
Within 45 minutes,
he had pulled up the wellhead. He'd coiled
the water, uh, called, called the pipe.
Uh, and, uh,
I recognize that I hadn't paid any
attention to the fact that that, uh,
the casing that surrounds the well could
convey water that had been contaminated
on the surface,
uh,
down the side of the casing and
into the underlying water supply.
I'll tell you more about the plastics side
of that story, uh, in a, in a few weeks.
So wells that, uh, uh,
service greater than 15 households are
regulated under the Safe Drinking Water
Act, which means that if a chemical
is listed on the EPA is list,
then community supplies have to test
for the presence of that chemical. A,
and if a maximum contaminant level has
been set, uh, that means that, that,
uh,
the provider has to demonstrate that
that ceiling has not been breached or he
would have to, he or she would have to
install some sort of filtration system.
So within Connecticut,
by the way,
that means that approximately a 30 to
40% of the Connecticut population, uh,
is getting water that has not managed in
any way by the safe drinking water act,
surface water.
In the United States is generally believed
now to be on drinkable for variety of
reasons, mostly because of
biological contamination. Uh,
the threat of [inaudible],
but also Giardia, which is carried
by both humans and by animals, uh,
in their waists, monitoring and
surveillance needs much improvement.
I'll talk more about the monitoring
system that is currently in place and why
it's deficient. A public water
infrastructure also is inadequate.
How many of you know, uh, the,
the way that water moves from
its source, uh, to your tap?
Uh, what, uh, what kind of
equipment does it go through?
What kind of filtration
does it go through?
What kind of land uses are allowed in the
watershed that surrounds the, the, uh,
the lakes and that, uh, provide
new haven's water supply. Uh,
and what about, uh, the pipes that
convey the water to wherever your tap is?
Do you know what they're made
out of? Are they plastic? Uh,
are they copper or they bronze? Are
they metal? Uh, or they are, excuse me.
Are they a,
are they leaded?
There are many connectors in many cities
that are quite old but are no longer
allowed to be installed that connect the
water main itself into your apartment
or into your house. Uh, but uh,
they exist and remain because
it's extremely expensive
to dig up every connector
and replace it with a one
that does not contain lead.
How about your faucet itself? Uh,
what's your faucet made out of? Well,
many faucets are made out
of brass and increasingly,
or they're made out of plastic plastic
that a is painted to look like it's metal
painted silver. Uh, you have to be
really careful when you buy a, uh, a,
a faucet system or you put in a
drinking water supply system, uh, to,
to really think
deeply about the source of the materials
and their leach ability into your
supply. The leach ability is driven by
a variety of factors. It could be heat.
Uh,
so for example,
you certainly would not want to make a
cup of tea by turning your hot water,
tap on a and then putting
a teabag in the water.
Or you wouldn't want to feed
infant formula to a small
child by putting powder,
uh, for example, in a,
in a glass and then not filling it up
with hot tap water because the hot tap
water is likely to leach more
compounds from the pipe or whatever.
The conveyance system is
a then cold water wood.
How long do you wait before you,
uh, to let the water run before you,
you take a drink out of your tap?
Make sense not to drink a water that,
that has been sitting
in your tap overnight.
They'd come back from vacation
for a couple of weeks. Uh,
we now recognize that a water
that sits in pipes takes,
takes up contaminants from
the conveyance system.
So all of these issues are, we're
thinking about in terms of infrastructure.
How about water rights? Really? What
are your rights to clean water on?
The core question of this
lecture is really, uh,
how safe is safe enough and
how do we define safe, uh,
particularly using the language of the
safe drinking water act. And finally,
how does land use affect water supply?
So many people are not at all thoughtful
about where watershed boundaries in the
vicinity of where they live.
They're not thoughtful about how
chemicals can migrate long distances.
I worked in,
in California,
in the central valley near Fresno for a
while on a project where chemicals were
recognized to migrate more than five miles
from their point of application to an
agricultural field, uh,
into underlying aquifers.
So it depends very much on the
underlying, uh, surficial geology,
the soil structure, the
bedrock, the groundwater
regime, how fast to a chemical,
we'll move some move a
really quite quickly.
Others move really quite slowly if
they can bind to organic matter.
So once again,
the safe drinking water act to cover
his supplies that have more than 14
connections or more than 24 individuals.
There are 53,000 water systems in the
United States and 43,000 of those rely on
groundwater and about 10,000 rely on
surface water and they're roughly split 50
50 public and private.
And there are 15 million wells in the
United States that serve individual
residences.
And roughly 45 million people,
maybe 15% of the population in the nation.
Uh,
our drinking water that
completely unregulated by
the safe drinking water act.
I wondered about this and
I wondered about, uh, uh,
what we could find out about
well, water vulnerability, uh,
and also if a casing
surrounding a well is cracked,
that means that chemical is
applied to the surface, uh,
have a higher chance of migrating
down the inside of the casing.
So I asked the Department of Environmental
Protection and the Department of
Health here in Connecticut,
if I could get ahold of their database,
a g I s a geographic information system
that they had that identified the
location of all wells in
Connecticut, all wells that, uh, uh,
uh,
had been mapped and geocoded.
And then I overlaid that data
with the surficial geology.
And then I started looking at old air
photos wondering about a former land uses.
And a pattern started to emerge
that a, in many areas, uh,
that had been former agricultural lands,
uh,
these have been developed
into residential areas, uh,
and wells had been dug into those areas,
provided unregulated water
supplies. Uh, to, uh,
uh, almost a million people in
the, in the state of Connecticut.
It's kind of an interesting story.
When I asked for that database,
I was denied access to it.
Uh,
this was post nine 11 because they
were worried about releasing the, the,
a geo coded data on precisely
where the wells were.
So I had to sign a paper that promise
that I would be legally responsible for
securing that data and
maintaining its confidentiality.
And I would not release it to
anybody who could do something, uh,
a nasty to a public water supply.
So
what about compliance? How are we doing
in the area in the area of compliance?
Well, 30 million people,
uh, drink a water each year.
Little Hiccup there.
For some reason,
30 million people drink water each year
from systems that report violations of
health based standards.
There are about 93 chemicals that are
not now on the safe drinking water list,
uh, that have maximum contaminant levels
assigned to them. So 30 million people,
10% of the population drinking
water that report, uh,
with that the systems have
reported are in violation.
10,000 systems violated health
based drinking water standards.
And about 80% of the public water
systems have reported no violations. Uh,
an EPA has issued 86,000 violations of
federal requirements to monitor or to
report results.
So the overwhelming number of violations
are associated with a failure to
monitor and the failure to report. So
if you don't look, if you don't monitor,
you can't find a problem.
And if you find a problem and
you're a municipal supplier, uh,
that's going to cost a lot of money.
You're either going to try to pass that
cost back on to consumers as increased
prices, uh, for, for, uh, prices
per gallon for their water. Uh,
uh, but certainly, uh, you're, you're
not going to want two, excuse me,
one second.
Yeah.
This commonly a delay in reporting.
So what does an MCL g a
maximum contaminant level
goal? EPA established, uh,
both the maximum contaminant level,
which is a legally enforceable women,
but they also established a
maximum contaminant level goal,
which is a health based ceiling.
So you would hope that the legal limit
would be the same as the health based
limit. Uh, but that's really not the case.
Okay.
So the safe drinking water
act, uh, creates, uh,
the contaminant level limit as the highest
concentration of a contaminant it's
allowed.
And it also allows a cost benefit
analysis that's required under the safe
drinking water act to consider what the
cost would be of meeting that, that, uh,
that limit. If the cost is
found to be excessively high,
they'll set a goal that would be higher
to protect human health and allow a
contamination level to
be higher than that.
So here's a chart that gets us to really
what our present level of regulation is.
A,
and you see that after the,
the safe drinking water act
was passed back in 1976 that,
uh, no new standards were
enacted. It's kind of interesting.
So Congress basically gives EPA
the mandate, uh, to regulate,
monitor water supplies. Uh, but EPA
doesn't really do very much about it. Uh,
this period in the late,
in the 1970s and early 1980s was a period
that EPA was concentrating on source
emissions, uh, from,
uh, uh, smokestacks, uh,
as well as auto emissions. Uh, and
also a variety of pesticides, uh,
but really it was paying very
little attention to drinking water.
So it added seven volatile
organic compounds in 1987 about a,
uh, 11 years later, uh, copper
and lead. We're not, uh, uh,
our revised, uh, based upon
new evidence of their toxicity,
uh,
from data that had been collected
back in the 1970s until 1991.
So remember, I argued earlier that there's
often this delay between recognizing,
uh, that, uh, a compound is more
hazardous than earlier thought, uh,
before the agency would take action and,
and set a new limit.
We're saying seeing the same
thing play out here. Well,
Congress was upset at this delay and a,
they demanded that a variety of new
chemicals be added and including a 39
pesticides, uh, volatile
organic compounds, metals. Uh,
so these were added in 1991. And then
during the period of the 1990s, uh,
seven years,
there were no new standards.
That's kind of interesting because
you might, uh, uh, uh, assume, uh,
quickly that a,
in a,
in a more liberal administration that,
uh,
you'd have more rapid
listing of chemicals,
you'd have a more protective a character.
This is not the case. Uh, so that, uh,
the,
uh,
the liberalism or the conservatism of
the administration seem to have little
influence on this rate rate of adoption.
So today we're sitting here with about
93 different chemicals and just to give
you a sense of, of, uh, how
limited, uh, coverage, uh,
and limited the protection level
is, uh, think, think about this.
But among the 39 pesticides, uh, that are,
are monitored and a have these
maximum contaminant limits,
there are approximately a thousand
more that are completely neglected.
Nobody's testing for them, but they're
allowed to be used on agricultural crops.
Uh, and many of these
have not been, uh, uh,
fully study to know how they move
through different kinds of ecosystems or
different kinds of geologic systems and
what their potential is to contaminate
the water supply. I think also that, uh,
more than 800 other chemicals,
including industrial chemicals,
have been detected in water supplies
by the u s geological service.
And by the way,
the u s geological services playing
a really unusual role in this,
in this a regulatory
process, uh, in that, uh,
they sit within the department of the
Interior. They're completely unrelated,
related to the environmental
protection agency,
but they're playing a more vigilant role
in monitoring chemical content and, and,
uh,
I hazards and underlying aquifers
as well as surface waters, uh,
than the environmental protection agency
had during this period of time. So this,
this is a history of neglect,
of a limited surveillance and it's
being driven by one fundamental
characteristic of the statute.
This is a listing statute,
which means that every time a new chemical
is discovered, uh, and EPA decides,
they, they hope to either, uh,
set a goal or to set a limit,
they're going to get a fight,
uh,
from the all the municipal suppliers
or the private suppliers because the
testing costs are going
to be passed on to them.
At least testing costs are
often not minor. Uh, by the way,
it's interesting to think about what the
effect might be of establishing a new
chemical limit. Well, it may
mean that, uh, you, you need to,
to conduct a, a, a brand new type of test,
it may also mean that you need to install
filtration equipment, uh, perhaps,
uh, activated carbon filtration,
which is extraordinarily expensive.
And the smaller the water system is,
uh,
the more expense it's going to
allocate per individual household.
So if New York City, for example, a,
is facing a new standard
that DPA has adopted a,
they can pass the cost of a monitoring
and filtration onto a very broad group of
people. Uh, but if you have a much
smaller community, say in the rural west,
uh, uh, of, uh, a couple of hundred
people in an isolated area, uh,
that's going to be much more
difficult for them to comply.
So there's been a trend
towards source protection, uh,
instead of consumer protection and a,
in part,
you can see this happening, uh, the,
what the public response to this has been,
which is to rely increasingly
on bottled water. And, uh,
many people have the perception
that bottled water is,
is much safer than tap water is.
Well,
it's not at all clear that that
is the case. Uh, many people, uh,
do not understand the filtration
techniques of bottled water companies. Uh,
we don't really have a
clear, clear standards. Uh,
and also many of the companies
that are marketing heavily in the,
in the United States are, are now,
uh, uh, foreign companies. So,
uh, the, the public's perception
of, uh, safety, uh, is,
is a really poorly founded
in scientific evidence. Also,
there's a story about plastic.
Uh, what about the, uh,
the plastic or the potential
plastic ingredients to
migrate into water supplies?
I'll give you one example. Uh,
I, uh, about 15 years ago, um,
I had bottled water in
my house, uh, as we were,
we were putting in a new, uh,
uh, water supply system. And,
uh, so the bottled water came in,
uh, a jug that was polycarbonate,
a five gallon jug. You probably
have all seen these, uh, that, uh,
you'd flip upside down. And,
uh, I had, uh, left that,
that bottle outdoors. Uh, actually
I'd been away for the weekend.
That was delivered on a Friday
during the summer months.
And the temperature had
gone up to about 102, uh,
and it was sitting on my driveway in
the sun when the ambient temperature was
102.
So it was really baking.
So when I opened the bottle and I
put it on the stand, I, I found that,
uh, it had a really, uh, very
accurate taste to it, a bitter taste.
So I called the water company and I
asked the, uh, uh, the bottling company,
you know, what might that be? And, uh, the
response was, oh, you know, we'll have a,
a new shipment out to you right away.
It was probably just the cleaning
agent or the disinfecting agent that a,
we put the bottles through. Well,
you know, I studied the, uh,
the problem more intensely
and found that, uh, uh,
they were using a disinfectant that a
was actually a registered pesticide. Uh,
and, and also this was perfectly
allowable, uh, because it,
it makes sense to try to disinfect water
bottles that are coming back that, uh,
may have had stagnant water within them.
Uh,
but somehow the rinsing process hadn't
effectively removed the cleaning agent.
Well, the bottled water problem,
uh, goes on in that, uh, uh,
I look more carefully at the potential
of plastics to migrate from the
polycarbonate into water and heat.
A solvent's solvents such as some
cell such, such as some biocides, uh,
uh, are, are mixed with, uh,
also a in the bottles themselves can
cause the chemicals to migrate more
frequently. Uh, the, the
offending chemical in this
case is [inaudible] la. Uh,
and, uh, we'll talk more about that later.
If you look across the maximum contaminant
limits and you compare them to the
public health goal. Uh, this study by
the state of California found that, uh,
the maximum contaminant limit,
the allowable concentration
was often too for a,
even 16 times higher. Uh, then the, uh,
health goal, uh, which
tells us that in many cases,
the agency is making a determination,
uh,
that we can be exposed to the
limit that they believe is,
is not health protective.
Uh,
there are other studies that have
demonstrated a similar finding, uh,
for other chemicals besides the elements.
So one of the ways to think about the
effectiveness of any statute is to think
carefully about how it's monitored.
Uh,
so what sampling design should be created
in order to figure out whether or not,
uh, we're effectively, uh, uh,
searching for chemicals that pose
the greatest threat. Well, you know,
I asked this question of the new
haven water, uh, authority and, uh,
found to my surprise that that the
systems of 25 to a thousand people,
uh, are only required to
provide one sample per month.
And it's pretty clear that, uh, there
are certain climatological events,
like a very serious rainstorms that
can wash contaminants off of surfaces,
whether it's an agricultural
field or a, a, uh, uh,
say a large shopping center parking lot,
uh,
into surrounding water supplies if
they are nearby. So thinking about, uh,
the importance of, uh, uh, the
sampling period is really critical.
Uh, and if recent reports have
demonstrated compliance with curtains,
certain standards,
uh,
then EPA allows the testing to be
limited to only four times per year.
And for some types of systems
such as new haven water company,
they've not found certain
pesticides. Uh, so they're,
they're allowed to monitor
only on an annual basis.
They can appeal to the
environmental protection agency
to reduce the periodicity
of their sampling.
And this of course,
is very important to them because
it saves them a lot of money.
Triazine herbicides provide a, a really
good example of this in the Midwest.
So triazine herbicides are there
known as a pre emergent herbicides,
and they're commonly sprayed on field
such as corn fields, uh, and, uh,
they're sprayed during
the spring in the spring.
And the Midwestern part of the United
States is a kind of famous for the
intensity of its rainstorms. So, uh, uh,
the sampling design relative to the rain
events really proved to be extremely
important to, to, uh, the findings. Uh,
you can pay more attention
to this slide online. Uh,
but these data demonstrate the ways that,
uh,
increasing the stringency of standards,
passes costs onto a water supply
companies and to people that are served,
uh, and really an inequitable way that
is dependent upon the size of the public
water system.
So I want to concentrate today and
tell you a story about this chemical.
This is, and that this is a triazine
herbicide and it's a, uh, uh,
now it's about a 27 year old story,
but the atrazine has become infamous as
one of the most heavily used herbicides
in the world. Uh, it's uses in the
United States include food crops,
uh, field corn, sweet corn, sugarcane,
sorghum, a winter wheat, guava,
macadamia nuts.
Uh,
it's used also on non food crops
such as Hay pasture lands. Uh,
it's also used in forestry.
It's also used in residential and
industrial and recreational areas, uh,
on residential turf, uh, within
parks and a on institutional turf,
also on golf courses.
And it's used for landscape maintenance.
And the whole idea behind an herbicide
is to kill other species of plants so
that they don't rob nutrients away from
the desired or highly valued plant. Uh,
so it's also sprayed on roadways.
And this is an interesting idea.
That'd be a great student project.
Now think about, uh, the, uh,
number of miles of roadways
in the United States, uh,
that are treated with herbicides.
Now, my town is a good example,
a little town of killing worth.
They don't like to cut the
vegetation next to the guard rails.
So what do they do instead?
They come along with a truck and
they just spray the side of the road.
Next time you get on Amtrak, uh,
take a look at the vegetation that,
that goes along the track and
you'll see almost nothing.
You'll see it devoid of vegetation.
How do they do that?
I said that just that they
didn't plan anything. No,
because seeds would blow into the area
and they would grow less chemicals were
applied.
So along major highways in the United
States along state highways, uh,
in many communities in areas that
have guard rails, a alarm, uh,
corridors that are used for
power, uh, power lines or,
or a rail, uh, on the, uh, uh,
runways of many air, air, airports,
uh, pesticides are applied.
So if you count up the total area in
the nation where these herbicides are
applied,
uh,
you can quickly get up to hundreds of
millions of acres of the landscape.
It's really quite striking. So, you know,
finding a chemical such as this, uh,
in the water supply really should
not be that much of a surprise,
but no one has really
looked systematically at
a where concentrations of
applications are going on.
But I'll give you one example of where
you might conduct this kind of a study.
And that's with a golf courses.
So that about $225 million per year in
the United States are spent on chemical
treatments of golf courses. There is
almost no landscape that I could imagine,
including agricultural lands that are
treated more intensely than golf courses
and particularly putting surfaces.
Uh,
so about $1,300 per acre,
a of 35,000 acres of putting surfaces are,
are receiving are uh,
quite a, uh, uh, a variety
of different, uh, uh,
bio Seidel compounds as a nation.
You know,
we need to think about where
are we applying chemicals
the most and we're doing
it predominantly to field crops.
Field Corn,
about 59 million acres of field
corn is treated sorghum sugar cane,
sweet corn, uh, and uh,
in both processed and a and fresh form.
So large percentages of these crops
are treated, uh, uh, with atrazine.
So if you map out the concentration
of atrazine and streams in the United
States, you see it centered on the
Midwestern part of the country.
And this is the primary corn
growing region. So the, uh,
I want you find is concentrations
in the microgram per liter level,
which is a part per billion level.
And the maximum concentration level,
the MCL for atrazine is a,
I believe it's a three or 4.3 and a.
If you look in the nation,
uh, what you find, excuse
me, parts per billion.
And if you look across the nation
to the number of people now that the
Environmental Protection
Agency think, uh, are,
are drinking residues of this
chemical in the water supply. Uh,
you see this adds up
to millions of people.
So large circles like the
one around Texas, you know,
represent more than 8 million people,
uh,
circles around Florida represent
a about 4 million people. Uh,
so you see that a,
they're finding it in the water where
it's most heavily used for agricultural
purposes.
So this was first registered
in 1958 and by registered me,
I mean it was given a license. It's like
a driver's license. Uh, so atrazine is,
it's regulated under the
Safe Drinking Water Act.
It's regulated under the clean water act
as well. And Epa began a special review,
uh, that they reserve for chemicals that
they have particular concerns about in
1994. Now, special review has had a, a,
a rather infamous history
in inside EPA. And, uh,
I have a good friend who graduated
from Yale who, who, uh, uh,
has worked her way up to a high level
inside the agency and she refers to EPA
parking lot and the parking lot is
a place where EPA stores chemicals,
not literally,
but figuratively when it decides it's not
going to take any regulatory action on
them. So atrazine was put in the
parking lot, so to speak, uh,
receiving a little attention for much
of the 1980s when these data came out,
when people realize that a,
the concentrations were going up.
Now when the parking lot fills
up, uh, with additional chemicals,
it basically means that, uh, uh,
the chemicals take longer and longer to
receive review and you have a lower and
lower probability, uh, that,
that a health based standards are going
to be set in response to new evidence of
serious contamination or risk.
Another problem with atrazine is that
it's structurally so similar to other
kinds of herbicides including
[inaudible] and proposition.
Uh, and it produces similar chlorinated
metabolites and metabolites are,
are, uh, uh, byproducts, uh,
that, uh, uh, the compound,
the original compound breaks into a,
that it makes sense to think about how
we might be exposed to clusters of these
compounds instead of
treating them individually.
So remember my argument earlier that EPA
is attention is focused chemical at a
time, so they'll make a
decision on atrazine without
thinking about Sam azine or
proposition.
But in terms of your exposure,
in terms of its behavior inside your body,
uh,
there is a presumption that that,
uh, chemicals that are similar,
so similar in structure will
behave similarly in your
body and impose a similar,
similar threat.
So as a society,
we want the government to pay
attention to these mixtures, uh,
particularly if there's a
plausible reason that, that, uh,
we might be exposed to the next years.
So in 1991,
the MCL was set at three parts
per billion, and the MCL,
Gigi was set up three parts
per billion, uh, as well.
And the compliance was determined based
upon a running annual average, uh,
with quarterly, quarterly samples
required by EPA. Or a single, uh,
average sample.
Also in the late 1980s,
this was classified as a possible
human carcinogen. Uh, but then, uh,
the environmental protections
production agency, uh,
reviewed it as not a likely
human carcinogen. Now, how
do they make these choices?
Well,
they submit evidence to what they
call a scientific advisory panel.
And I've had the experience of sitting
on EPA scientific advisory panels for
nearly a decade and reviewing new evidence
of risk and the decision on the part
of the panel to recommend a classification
as a carcinogen or not a carcinogen
or chemicals of high
concern or low concern. Uh,
it really depends very much upon who is
asked to sit on the scientific advisory
panel. And I want to recommend to you
the work of a professor at Harvard,
Sheila Jazz.
And off she,
Sheila came here as a visiting professor
for a while and her work has been very
important on what she calls the,
uh, fifth branch of government, uh,
which are these advisory panels.
So evidence is often so complex that an
agency is not really clear what they're
going to do. Uh, is the risk higher?
Is it lower? Should we regulate? Uh,
should we just, uh, uh, warn
people? How are we going to,
how are we going to manage this chemical?
They'll submit this question
to a scientific advisory
panel to gain their advice
while the political makeup of these
panels makes a terrific difference. Uh,
depending in guiding the ultimate outcome.
So the food and Drug Administration,
the Occupational Safety and
Health Administration, EPA,
most regulatory agencies rely very
heavily on the scientific advisory panels.
But just because the scientific advisory
panel makes a recommendation, uh,
doesn't mean that you ought to,
you ought to believe it.
Prior Regulation, uh, uh,
they looked at the chemical a more
intensely and they found that prior
regulation was insufficient, uh,
so that they deleted range land,
millet and pineapple uses. So instead
of prohibiting the chemical outright,
they would look at particular
uses, uh, probably uses that,
did not have a very high economic value
and decided to go after those two to
prohibit or further restrict those.
They also use what they call it,
a restricted use classification and
pesticide law. Fifth, uh, the acronym,
Federal Insecticide fungicide.
And rodenticide act, uh, it,
it has this restricted use classification.
This is an interesting idea.
I was telling a section last night
that it's similar to the idea of a,
of a pharmacist, a in other words, uh,
in the world of pharmaceuticals,
we had this intervening layer of expertise
so that the pharmacist plays a role
of interpreting exactly
what the appropriate dose
is a four for you. So the,
the, the physician doesn't give
you the drug directly normally,
although this happens in a, in
a hospital often, uh, but, uh,
in the pharmacy you get access to a
chemical that poses certain risks,
uh, because experts are there to behind
the counter, uh, to make sure that,
that you're getting the proper dose
and that you understand that, uh,
there could be drug
interactions or that, uh, uh,
there may be certain side effects
that you should be aware of.
So this same concept was
built into pesticide law,
but in a very different way of
training licensed applicators.
So if a chemical is classified as being
restricted use because it is more toxic
or it's more persistent, or it poses
a certain kind of a health threat,
then someone has to be trained before
they're allowed legally to apply it.
And within the pesticide regulations,
uh,
there is a provision so that
supposing I went and I got my license,
so I was licensed to apply dangerous
chem, dangerous pesticides, uh,
particularly in a, he
say restricted, uh, uh,
areas that were ecologically vulnerable
or maybe inside schools or hospitals.
So that I have the legal authority to
delegate that responsibility to you.
And if you have no training at all,
uh, makes no difference. I mean,
I would tell you what to do.
I would tell you to follow the
label directions very carefully. Uh,
but remember what I was saying about
literacy and background literacy. So, uh,
how do you mix, uh, uh,
how do you mix a, a, a,
a quarter ounce of a toxic substance in,
say,
water in kerosene or some other, uh, uh,
solvent that it's
supposed to be sprayed in?
And how do you know that you've got
exactly the right concentration?
Will it take some
mathematical skill to do that?
And I run across a couple of cases
that I was describing last evening,
where people that, uh, were
delegated this authority, uh,
not only had a minimum level of literacy,
but also had virtually no mathematical
capacity to make these kinds of
judgments. So Epa realize this
eventually and they started, uh,
requiring containers that
were in a sense foolproof, uh,
so that you would have a, you would tip
it, they call it a tip and poor mechanism.
So you could pour out only a,
the correct proportion
of the active ingredient.
And then all you had to figure out was
whether or not you had to add one or,
or two gallons to, so this
reduced the, uh, the error rate.
But if you are spraying a
pesticide as an example and a,
you've got a backpack on and
you've got a, a spray wand, I mean,
I could be a spraying the, a, the edge
of this podium and walking along, uh,
my cell phone could ring, I could
stop. It could look at my watch, um,
and then I could move on. Uh, and
the effect would be what? Well,
when I looked at my watch,
wherever the wand was pointing,
it would get a dose that probably would
be dozens of times higher than if I were
walking in a uniform way.
It's kind of an interesting analog to
that with respect to a spray planes or,
or tractors. So you can imagine
a tractor that has a, uh, a,
a bar across the back of it, uh, across
the back end with holes on it, such as,
as it, uh, going to irrigate
a field. Well, no, the,
the truck goes along,
it gets to the end of the field,
it turns around and comes back this way,
and eventually it covers the entire field.
Well,
if it has the same application
rate, uh, the same, uh,
emission rate from the pipe or
regardless of the speed of the truck, uh,
were in the field, are you going
to get the higher concentrations
at the ends of the field where the truck
slows to, to turn around. Similarly,
if you can think about a spray plane
coming in and uh, uh, spraying a,
the hypothetical field, which is
the, uh, the platform up here, uh,
they pass this way, then they come
back, then they passed another way.
I've seen farm workers in California
standing there and with just shorts and a
straw hat on,
kind of waiting as a,
as a marker for the spray
plane being sprayed repeatedly.
There's an occupational
side to a pesticide control
that I don't have time to
express to you.
Uh,
but then you get this overlap
of the spray in the field.
So these have these kinds of,
uh,
practical conditions have a
really important implication
for how you set up your
sampling design. So if you sampled
in the middle of the field, uh,
that was treated by the
truck or the tractor,
you're going to get a lower
level of concentration that
if sampled at the end of
the field, the same may be the
case with respect to, to, uh, uh,
spray planes and a,
the way that they spray fields.
So the dance or regulation a is one
where, uh, the government will say, look,
we've got to cut back your, your
use. We have to protect the water or,
or we want to reduce the
worker exposure. And the, uh,
industry that manufactures that will
say, well, you know what, uh, uh,
don't cut back in this area,
uh,
cutback and restrict its use
on a specific commodity. Uh,
probably one that is not a, uh, uh,
an economically productive one for them,
uh,
or a particular kind of use.
So the argument about what uses are
restricted as opposed to which ones are
prohibited gets quite
technical quite quickly.
So if a chemical comes back as a
recognized serious threat to human health,
that doesn't mean it's going to be
prohibited. Prohibition is very unlikely.
I mean, there've been so few bands
and environmental history, uh,
probably fewer than a 300 bands
outright bans of chemicals.
I talked to you about a couple of
them. Ddt is a good example. Uh,
and Aldrin and chlordane chlordane.
These are all pesticides, but, uh,
for the vast majority of compounds,
instead you get this,
a minor revision in the way the chemical
is allowed to be mixed or applied is
put into the restricted use category
that's allowed to be used on corn but not
on another crop. Uh, so that, uh, uh,
the market share can be maintained.
Here's a graph of the seasonal
pulse of atrazine in water supplies.
Uh, that was recognized in the
Midwestern part of the United States.
You can't see the years here,
but this is 1995, 1996, 1997,
1998.
And you see this pulse that because
they apply it in the spring and then the
rains will like wash it into the
surrounding, uh, water supplies. Well,
so another sampling design issue
here that really is critical to the
effectiveness,
the effectiveness of the statute is that
if you decided that you were going to
sample, say in September of each year,
uh, you're going to miss this pulse.
So it's only by, uh, uh, you know, sitting
down and thinking about the, the, uh, uh,
method of application. The timing
of the application, uh, and,
and thinking about it, uh, in a more
systems or ecological men or, uh,
that considers climate, uh, that, uh,
you would be able to pick this up.
And there was a very interesting
legal debate as well about, uh,
what this chemical is doing, where
it's moving. Uh, and the, uh,
US geological service found
that it travels actually
hundreds of miles from its
site of applications.
So it's running off the fields,
it's getting into streams and
it's getting into rivers, uh,
such as the Mississippi River.
It's moving long distances. So, uh,
this study found that states,
uh,
some states will receiving 50% of their
pollution load, uh, from out of state.
So if atrazine is a
reaching, say Louisiana, uh,
but we know that it's not applied in
Louisiana, what right do they have to,
to sue,
uh,
the Environmental Protection Agency for
the failure to regulate that chemicals
application up in Ohio or
Illinois or in, uh, Minnesota.
And, uh, they do have the authority to see
the environmental protection agency or,
or a, a particular chemical
companies that are responsible.
So this transboundary movement of, of, uh,
of these chemicals raises
a very serious issue.
And also you've got to think
about the fact that that, uh,
many of these cities get their water
supplies from these rivers, uh,
and they use filtration systems that
do not have the capacity to extract,
uh,
many of the pesticides that are used.
So water is typically filtered by
running it through sand to take out
particulate matter. Uh, then it's
treated with, uh, with chlorine.
It's not normally treated with gay, uh,
activated carbon, uh, which could barn to,
to this,
to these chemicals.
Now that shouldn't ring bells in your
head if you're concerned about your own
water intake because water is the
most consumed food in your diet. Uh,
it should ring a bell that you should be
concerned about the quality of water in
your tap. And you should think
carefully about the wisdom of,
of using activated carbon at the tap,
uh,
because it's not likely that
the government has, has, uh,
kept it perfectly safe.
So I'm going to scoot ahead here,
uh, with one final
aspect of this story. Uh,
the atmospheric transport of
some of these chemicals, uh,
was a surprise to many inside the agency
as well as the scientific community.
I ran into this in California,
uh, when I found that a chemical,
a dry died bromo chloro propane that had
been injected into the soil and cotton
fields,
uh,
had actually volatilized
and gotten up into the fog.
Anybody here from the Central Valley?
Well, the Central Valley of California,
which is sandwiched between coastal
range, uh, and then the, the, uh,
Sierras is a flat basin.
It's a former lake bed
and climatologically it's
interesting because of fog will
settle on that area, uh, and
stay there for a good part,
a of January, sometimes December
six, two to eight weeks. Uh,
so what they found was DPCP,
uh,
was actually volatilizing and
it was detectable in the fog.
They found toxaphene that had been
applied in Texas, uh, in the Great Lakes.
Uh, then they found atrazine,
uh, in the Great Lakes as well.
So [inaudible] 0.6% of atrazine
is deposited in one study,
uh,
and rainfall and the concentration
of atrazine in precipitation,
uh, in some areas were, had not been
applied, was one part per billion.
And what was,
what did I tell you?
The maximum contaminant level
was three parts per billion,
but fairly striking. Uh, so it's moving
long distances in clouds and raining down,
uh, and you know, perhaps
acting as a, uh, uh,
pre emergent herbicide to areas that were,
it was never intended to be used.
So the degradation of the chemical and
aquatic environments is increasingly
concerned.
The half life is between
41 and 237 days on average,
half life of the chemical of 159 days.
Uh,
and Lake Michigan, uh, is a repository
for atrazine because of its use,
particularly in Minnesota
and Michigan, Indiana, Ohio,
and the pattern of rainfall in that area.
So it's cold water, it's low
productivity, it's high Ph,
low nitrate and low dissolved oxygen,
uh,
all contribute to increase
persistent of the chemical.
So the estimated halflife, uh, in
Lake Michigan is about 31 years.
So Epa conducted a study that
found that, that, uh, I, they,
when they tried to figure out what the
mass balance was at atrazine or is of
atrazine.
So atmospheric wet deposition is
about 2,493 kilograms per year.
Uh, the watershed loading directly in
surface water runoff to the lake is about
5,000 kilograms per year,
2,500 kilograms exported to Lake Huron,
and, uh, it's exported to a
Chicago, uh, by water diversions, a,
a more minor amount, and even the lake
itself is verbalizing the chemical.
So recognizing that the agricultural
practice of, of, uh, uh,
using atrazine as an herbicide and
EPA is neglect of this compound and
misunderstanding of its ecological
behavior, uh, could, uh,
cause a gradual buildup to 182,000
kilograms of the compounds sitting in the
lake. It was really quite striking. Uh,
so I'm gonna just pause with
reflections on, on, uh, uh,
the work of Tyrone Hayes, who is a, uh,
a former chemical company employee,
a scientist who worked
for Syngenta and, uh, uh,
Tyrone Hayes has been responsible
for some controversial work. Uh,
so he took his students and he,
uh,
rented a tractor trailer and they
drove across the country, uh,
taking a look at the concentrations
of atrazine and leopard frogs.
And a what was interesting
about his finding a,
because he sampled from areas of the
country, uh, where the leopard frogs live,
but to atrazine was not used.
And then he went into the heart of
the Midwestern atrazine use belt, uh,
and sampled in those areas. And he found
to obviously higher concentrations, uh,
in the, in the areas where it
was used. But he also found, uh,
that, uh, these frogs had
both ovaries and testes.
So his argument is that, uh, this
chemical is hormonally active,
at least in, uh, the African clawed frog.
And he, he also is claiming that, uh,
there are important lessons
here for humans, uh,
that this compound could be also
hormonally active in humans. So atrazine,
he argues, uh, in a exposed males
that have ovaries in their testes,
uh, also had much smaller larynx's and
larynx's are important if you're a frog,
because it's a way that you can understand
where other frogs are or other frauds
can understand where you are a
for reproductive success. Uh,
and it's also recognized to lower
that the testosterone levels in frogs.
So I'm not going to go further today
other than to suggest that there's a whole
emerging area of concern now about
hormonally active compounds. Uh,
and atrazine is a good compound to, to pay
attention to. Okay. That's it for today.
Thank you very much.